and so I said oh you know nothing Jon  Snow  miss the lessons  really um I said that was an epic last  episode adore I gotta tell you something  I haven't even gotten to the red wedding  episode guys Ava's being such a Joffrey  right now I know he's the best the best  Joffrey's the worst Oh got you oh hey um  can I ask you something really quickly  am I the only one who gets the  Lannisters in this no traffic was a  nightmare I almost went into Khaleesi  mode you know respect that Patrol now is  that from Harry Potter adorned ask you  question yeah winners over right like a  spring now  oh hey there's some Jaime Cersei stuff  going on here yeah a whole lot of that  yep okay I have got to tell you  something okay I'm tired of lying hi  I've never seen game of oh my god me  neither  Oh what the door no door you guys don't  come over Sunday not invited anymore  in Geoffrey's